all right the second presidential debate
in st. Louis over the weekend moderated
by Martha Raddatz and Anderson Cooper so
far we've had the first of three
presidential debates and the one and
only vice presidential debate on Sunday
we had the second presidential debate it
was a very depressed and sort of somber
Donald Trump who proved to be completely
classless in every single way
a bizarre lease talking behind Hillary
Clinton throughout the debate looking
dark-looking truly truly depressed
darkened and almost just resentful and
angry and the most difficult thing about
these debates is that Hillary Clinton
has this impossible task of having to
pretend like she's in a real debate with
someone who has a clue about anything
and that can be really tough Hillary
Clinton had to keep this face on knowing
that there was a reaction shot of her
for a lot of the debate where she had to
act like Donald Trump was even a
remotely reasonable person who knew
anything and he didn't and that was
really really tough Trump in his first
answer managed to connect the leaked
audio [ __ ] gate comments to Isis which
I don't think we've seen before I don't
know that we'll ever see again in our
lifetimes and and in my head the way I
was hearing the questions go from Trump
to Clinton from the moderators would go
to Trump he would just rant
unintelligibly and I almost felt like
the way they should go to Hillary
Clinton is Secretary Clinton you look
like you recognize some of the words in
this question do you want to take a shot
at answering because Trump just would
not answer a single question let's start
with whether Trump understands that he
claimed to have sexually assaulted women
in the leaked audio tape we received a
lot of questions online mr. Trump about
the tape that was released on Fridays
you can imagine you called what you said
locker room banter you described kissing
women without consent grabbing their
genitals that is sexual assault you
bragged that you have sexually assaulted
women do you understand that I didn't
say that at all I don't think you
understood what was that this was locker
room talk I'm not proud of it I
apologize to my family I apologized to
the American people certainly I'm not
proud of it but this is locker room
you know when we have a world where you
have Isis chopping off heads where you
have and frankly drowning people in
steel cages where you have Wars and and
horrible horrible sites all over where
you have so many bad things happening
this is like medieval times we haven't
seen anything like this the carnage all
over the world yeah first time in
history that [ __ ] grabbing and Isis
have been connected Donald Trump has
done it and with lots of sniffing and
sniffling to go along with it then let's
go to Donald Trump again sort of
following up about this entire leaked
audio using the it's just words response
yet to some questions I assume I am yes
it's just words folks it's just words
those words I've been hearing him for
many years
I heard them when they were running for
the Senate in New York where Hillary was
going to bring back jobs to upstate New
York and she failed I've heard them
where Hillary is constantly talking
about the inner cities of our country
which are a disaster education-wise
job boy safety well yeah so Trump just
rambling words have no meaning anymore
it's an alternate universe except that
every time Trump says something and says
it has no meaning then we find more and
more evidence that for him it actually
really does have meaning and the leaked
audio tapes no exception here is where
Trump you could see him thinking am I
gonna mention Bill Clinton or am I not
gonna mention Bill Clinton and he did
here's that moment from the debate if
you look at Bill Clinton far worse minor
words and his was action his words what
he's done to women there's never been
anybody in the history of politics in
this nation that's been so abusive to
women so you can say any way you want to
say it but Bill Clinton was abusive to
women Hillary Clinton attacked those
same women and attacked them viciously
four of them here tonight one of the
women who is a wonderful woman at 12
years old was raped at 12 her client she
represented got him off and she's seen
laughing on two separate occasions
laughing at the girl who was raped okay
now here we're gonna get to one of the
most controversial moments from the
debate which culminated with Trump
telling Hillary Clinton that if he were
president she would be in jail so let's
start with how Trump went into this
talking about Bernie Sanders not losing
fair and square and wiki weeks and then
mentioning a special prosecutor yeah and
all you have to do is take a look at
WikiLeaks and just see what they said
about Bernie Sanders and see what Debra
Wasserman Schultz had in mind because
Bernie Sanders between super-delegates
and Debra Wasserman Schultz he never had
a chance and I was so surprised to see
him sign on with the devil but when you
talk about apology I think the one that
you should really be apologizing for and
the thing that you should be apologizing
for are the 33,000 emails that you
deleted and that you acid-washed and
then the two boxes of emails and other
things last week that were taken from an
office and are now missing and I'll tell
you what I didn't think I'd say this but
I'm going to say it and I hate to say it
but if I win I am going to instruct my
Attorney General to get a special
prosecutor to look into your situation
because there has never been so many
lies so much deception and then the
crowning achievement of the second
debate in a way reminiscent of Hitler or
Mussolini or other dictators the entire
I will jail my political opponents idea
that we have seen the world over from
really really bad people Trump says
Hillary would be in jail if he were
president so once again go to Hillary
Clinton calm we have literally Trump you
can fact check a fat check fat check in
real time yeah last time at the first
debate we had millions of people
fact-checking so I expect we'll have
millions more fact-checking because you
know it is it's just awfully good that
someone with the temperament of Donald
Trump is not in charge of the law in our
country because you'd be in jail yeah
and the trumpeters just absolutely
loving it loving loving loving it loving
as many authority
do the idea of democratically elected
officials threatening to put their
political opponents in jail not exactly
the calling card of the United States
but it is apparently for Donald Trump
now the Muslim ban what is the
explanation on the Muslim ban we sort of
heard about it from Trump let's take a
look at that clip mr. Trump in December
you said this Donald J Trump is calling
for a total and complete shutdown of
Muslims entering the United States until
our country's representatives can figure
out what the hell is going on we have no
choice we have no choice go on your
running mate said this week that the
Muslim ban is no longer your position is
that correct and if it is was it a
mistake to have a religious test first
of all
captain Khan is an American Hero right
and if I were president at that time he
would be alive today
sure because unlike her who voted for
the war without knowing what she was
doing I would not have had our people in
Iraq Iraq was a disaster why so he would
have been alive today the Muslim ban is
something that in some form has morphed
into a extreme vetting from certain
areas of the world Hillary Clinton wants
to allow me all the time what are you to
explain whether or not the Muslim ban
still stands it's called extreme vetting
we are going to areas like Syria where
they're coming in by the tens of
thousands because of Barack Obama yeah
so extreme vetting is now the plan which
is also known as the system we already
have in place and then one of the funny
moments this is just one example but it
was spread throughout the debate Trump
complaining about Hillary Clinton
getting more time than he did he
shouldn't have
she just went about 25 seconds over her
time respond to this place very quickly
please she kept Martha Hillary went
25 seconds over I mean yes I interrupted
four times waved my arms at the
moderators twice and sniffed and
sniffled over the entire thing but she
went over Martha except it wasn't true
Trump had more speaking time 40 minutes
and 10 seconds during this debate versus
only 39 minutes and 5 seconds for
Hillary Clinton in spite of complaining
about speaking time the entire debate
and then I'm going to present this to
you as Trump's strongest moment of the
debate it's only 11 seconds ok I I had
to dig really deep to find a strong
moment this I believe was Trump's
strongest moment in the debate take a
look she complains that Donald Trump
took advantage of the tax cut well why
didn't she change it why didn't you
change it when you were a senator the
reason you didn't is that all your
friends take the same advantage should I
do what I do
so unfortunately Hillary Clinton did
actually vote to have the tax loophole
they're referring to close but there was
not a majority so it was not closed when
she was a senator optically one of Trump
strongest moments unfortunately it did
not really make any sense and then a
blockbuster moment Trump admitting that
of course he used that 916 million
dollar loss in 1995 to avoid paying
federal taxes in the future the New York
Times published three pages of your 1995
tax returns they show you claimed a 960
million dollar loss which means you
could have avoided paying personal
federal income taxes for years you've
said you pay state taxes employee taxes
real estate taxes property taxes you
have not answered though a simple
question did you use that 916 million
dollar laws to avoid paying personal
federal income taxes of course I do
of course I do and so do all of her
donors or most of her donors I know many
of her donors yeah and here is the last
moment I will play for you which is
Donald Trump asking a really important
question after an unintelligible rant
about foreign policy I think Aleppo is a
disaster humanitarian was I think that
it basically has fallen okay it
basically is fun let me tell you
something you take a look at Mosul the
biggest problem I have with the
stupidity of our foreign policy we have
they think a lot of the Isis leaders are
in Russell so we have announcements
coming out of Washington and coming out
of Iraq we will be attacking Mosul in
three weeks or four weeks while all of
these bad leaders from Isis are leaving
muscle why can't they do it quietly why
can't they do the attack make it a sneak
attack and after the attack is made
inform the American public that we've
knocked out the leaders we've had a
tremendous success people leave why do
they have to say we're going to be
attacking Mosul within the next four to
six weeks which is what they're saying
how stupid is our country that is the
question ladies and gentlemen how stupid
is our country we'll find out on
November 8th won't we will take a break
and be back with more after this the
david pakman show is sponsored this week
by decode DC the podcast that gives you
an honest look into how politics affects
your life the host of decode DC is Jimmy
Williams and he is a very interesting
guy he worked in politics on both sides
of the aisle starting as a Republican
becoming a Democrat he's worked as a
lobbyist he does know his stuff and he's
taking that experience and explaining
the internal dynamics of how Washington
DC works Ducote DC will often dig into
topics that you know I'm passionate
about money in politics for example
including a recent show about why
small-dollar donors don't actually
produce winning political candidates
check it out I did I think you will love
it we are talking about decode DC it's
available on iTunes stitcher or wherever
you get your podcasts